tenemos aquí a la función f x definida
como un polinomio y lo que quiero que
hagamos en este vídeo es encontrar la
derivada de f o sea básicamente
encontrar la derivada de este polinomio
y por cierto queremos la derivada con
respecto a x pero bueno lo primero que
vamos a hacer es sacar la derivada de
los dos lados la derivada con respecto a
x de f de x es igual a la derivada con
respecto a x del polinomio x a las 5 más
2 x al cubo menos x al cuadrado ahora
acerca de la anotación podríamos pensar
en esto como el operador derivar y lo
que nos dice es que encontremos la
derivada de lo que está entre paréntesis
con respecto a x y entonces aquí tenemos
la derivada de fx con respecto a x a la
cual muchas veces también le llamamos
fue prima de x y esto va a ser igual a
la derivada del polinomio con respecto a
x pero aquí podemos usar algunas
propiedades de la derivada y
simplificarlo un poco sabemos que la
derivada de la suma de algunos términos
es igual a la suma de la derivada de
cada uno de esos términos entonces vamos
a escribir por aquí la derivada de cada
uno de estos tres términos es igual a la
derivada con respecto de x de este
término más la derivada con respecto de
x de el segundo término menos la
derivada con respecto a x de el último
término porque aquí tenemos este menos
vamos a escribirlo con colores distintos
aquí tenemos x elevado a la potencia 5x
elevado a los 5 es
es 2x elevado a la 32 x a la 3 y luego
restamos x al cuadrado x a la 2 y listo
lo único que estamos haciendo es tomando
la derivada de cada uno de estos
términos por separado y después sumando
los si estábamos sumando estos términos
o restando la derivada si estábamos
restando ese término y esto es igual a
que aquí podemos utilizar la regla de
las potencias tomamos el exponente y lo
multiplicamos por acá y luego le
restamos 1 al exponente y lo que nos
queda es 5 5
x elevada a las 5 menos 10 5
1 es 4 y luego para el segundo término
otra vez usamos la regla de las
potencias pero podemos hacerlo paso por
paso para que sea más fácil la derivada
con respecto a x de 2x a la potencia 3
es igual a aquí vamos a tomar este
coeficiente y lo vamos a sacar de la
derivada y nos queda 2 por la derivada
con respecto de x de x elevado a la
tercera potencia ahora esto de aquí es
una de las propiedades de la derivada si
tenemos la derivada de una constante por
una expresión eso es igual a la
constante
la derivada de esa expresión y ahora
cuál es la derivada de x a la 3 pues
sabemos que tomamos el exponente lo
ponemos por acá multiplicando y le
restamos 1 al exponente y entonces nos
queda 2 por 3 3
x elevada a la 3 menos 10 3 -1 es 2 y
esto en total nos da 6 por x al cuadrado
aquí podríamos haber puesto simplemente
6 por x al cuadrado que es lo que
obtuvimos acá pero como te darás cuenta
muy pronto esto se puede hacer muy fácil
en la cabeza podemos tomar el exponente
y multiplicarlo por el coeficiente y al
final de cuentas también hicimos eso por
acá y 3 por el coeficiente es 6 por
equis elevado a la 3 menos 103 menos uno
es 2 y listo ya terminamos no teníamos
que hacer todo lo que hicimos por acá
pero está bastante bien ver esto para
que nos demos cuenta de que esto
proviene de las propiedades de las
derivadas que ya vimos en algunos otros
vídeos
y restamos la derivada del último
término y para encontrarla vamos a
utilizar
otra vez la regla de las potencias
tomamos el exponente lo colocamos al
principio y le restamos 1 al exponente
entonces ponemos al principio el 2 por
equis a la 2 menos 1 pero 2 menos uno es
simplemente uno que podemos escribirlo
simplemente como x así es que ya tenemos
por aquí la derivada de f y tú tal vez
podrías preguntarme oye pero esto que es
bueno pues esta es una expresión que
describe la pendiente de la recta
tangente a la función f en el punto x
también podemos decir que es la tasa de
cambio instantánea con respecto a x para
cualquier valor de x por ejemplo que tal
que queremos calcular f prima en 2
pues esto lo que nos dice es cuál es la
pendiente de la recta tangente a la
función f cuando x es igual a 2 y
encontramos de esa pendiente utilizando
esta expresión así es que esto es igual
a 5 por 2 a la 4 más
por dos a las dos menos dos por dos por
aquí
2 a la 4 es 16 y 16 por 5
todo esto es 80 más 2 al cuadrado es 4
por 6 24 y luego 2 por 24 entonces
tenemos 80 más 24 104 y luego menos 4 o
sea 100 esto es igual a 100 entonces
cuando x es igual a 2 esta curva está
súper empinada porque la pendiente es
100 si graficar amos la recta tangente a
la función efe cuando x es igual a dos
por cada pequeño movimiento que viéramos
en alguno de los dos sentidos tendríamos
que movernos 100 veces ese movimiento en
el eje del ay es así es que es una
gráfica muy empinada lo cual tiene
bastante sentido porque aquí tenemos un
exponente bastante grande
le estamos sumando otro exponente que
también está bastante grande x a las 5
si es un exponente bastante grande